d'après les renseignements devraient
s'approcher
on est en train de chuter
pour attaquer l'ordre nous avons aussi
obtenu les codes d'identification de la
RAF
qu'est-ce
que s'il te plaît
ils ont développé un truc ils appellent
la super arme d'après ce que je sais il
s'agit d'une bombe qui pourrait détruire
une ville entière
on a des nouvelles de Friedman on a
entendu un des gardes qu'ils allaient le
transférer où ça ça vous voulez pas le
savoir il faut qu'on trouve un moyen de
sortir il nous faudra un miracle pour
sortir d'ici alors va nous falloir un
miracle
je ne veux pas de médaille je veux
l'Américain
on va prendre le chemin par lequel je
suis arrivé d'accord
[Musique]
bien joué je suis impressionné tu parles
bien trop